[संगीत]
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग दोस्तों एक बार
सभी बता दीजिए की सबको मेरी आवाज ए रही है
नहीं ए रही प्लीज कंफर्म कर दीजिए
[संगीत]
चाट में
मुझे कुछ लोग यहां पर
पहले से आप पढ़ रहे हो बताइए थोड़ा सा
बताइए
ओके तो देखिए जिन लोगों का फर्स्ट दे है
याद डायरेक्ट लाइव क्लास में तो आप लोगों
को पता होना चाहिए की हमारी टोटल
क्लासेस हो चुकी है ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस
के ऊपर जो ऑलरेडी आपकी सीरीज अवेलेबल
नहीं आने वाली
वह चीज बिल्कुल भी आपको समझ में नहीं आने
वाले तो इसलिए प्लीज एक कम कीजिए पुरी चीज
सीरीज को आपको कंपलीटली देखना है इस के
बाद आपको ज्यादा ही हां पीछे वाला को कर
करना ही पड़ेगा क्योंकि यह बिल्कुल और चल
रहा है बी ऑप्शन इंटेलिजेंस का अगर आपको
पीछे का कर नहीं किया तो आप क्या है की आज
मैं जो क्लासेस लेने वाला हूं जो भी मैं
आप लोगों को पढ़ना वाला हूं वो क्या चीज
है की वो एक इंटरमीडिएट है ऐसा नहीं की
मैं बेगिनेर क्योंकि जो चीज मैं ऑलरेडी
कुछ टाइम से मेरा सोशल मीडिया ओपन सोशल
इंटेलिजेंस चल रहा है तो उसमें वो साड़ी
चीजें बार-बार रिपीट हो रही है कुछ शब्द
कुछ बातें तो अब मैं क्या उनको अवार्ड
करूंगा क्योंकि ताकि आप लोग बर ना हो तो
मैं सीधा क्या टेक्निक्स पे बात करने वाला
जो हम टेक्निक्स टूल्स उसे करने वाले हैं
तो अब मैं आज आपको टेक्निक्स टूल्स बता
दूंगा क्योंकि ओपन 100 इंटेलिजेंस
इंस्टाग्राम के ऊपर नया है आप देख लीजिए
आपको कोई बिल्कुल भी सनी होने वाला है बट
काफी एटलिस्ट आपको क्या है लास्ट के सारे
क्लास कर करनी होगी दे वन तू थ्री फोर
जितनी भी है टोटल तक आपको कल करनी ही होगी
तभी आपको
शायद आपको साड़ी चीज समझ में भी है और
अच्छी भी लगी
है तो आज जो हमारा टॉपिक है वह
इंस्टाग्राम ओपन सोशल इंटेलिजेंस हम
इंस्टाग्राम करने वाले हैं और आप लोगों को
पता है पहले से ही हम एजुकेशन प्रपोज के
लिए मेटा कंपनी को टारगेट करके बैठे हुए
हैं नोटरी रिजल्ट टारगेट बस ओनली जस्ट पर
प्रैक्टिस और एजुकेशन परपज ओनली और उनके
जो सीईओ हैं ये जो फाउंडर्स हैं वो
मार्क्स से कर क है ये उनकी प्रोफाइल्स
हैं आप लोगों को पता है की जब भी हम अभी
तक जितने भी हमने इंस्टाग्राम फेसबुक लिंक
दें जितने भी अपन सोशल ट्रेड किया है इसे
तो वहां पर सभी से हमें क्या आएगी यही हर
एक यूजरनेम हर एक उसके लिए जस्ट नाम के
एक-एक प्रोफाइल देखने को मिली है जो मार्ग
की है जो उनके
फाउंडर्स है उनकी साड़ी की साड़ी प्रोफाइल
तो किसी भी हैकिंग स्टीरियो के लिए तो अभी
क्या है की फिर से हम एक बार मैं आपको
चीजों को याद दिल देता हूं आपको सबको पता
है की जितने भी सोशल मीडिया प्लेटफॉर्म पर
हम जितने
सोशल मीडिया प्लेटफॉर्म के बड़े में साइन
आपका फेसबुक को इंस्टाग्राम हो ट्विटर हो
तो सभी में क्या है दो मेटालर्जी के साथ
कम किया जाता है सबसे पहले माइथॉलजी कौन
सी होती है ट्रेडिशनल मेथड होता है एक
दूसरा जिसे हम बोलते हैं नॉन टेक्निकल
मेथड दूसरा जो मेथड होता है वो होता है
टेक्निकल मेथड बोलते हैं तो ट्रेडिशनल
मेथड का आप अच्छी तरह भले मानते ही उसे
करना जानते हैं क्योंकि आप सभी
इंस्टाग्राम करते हो और आप लोगों को
इंस्टाग्राम उसे करना आता है तो इसलिए
क्या है की आप कुछ नहीं मानते पता है की
टेंशन मत लो कौन सा होता है
बेसिकली मैं आपको बता दूंगा कोई एग्जांपल
मेरे पास अब टारगेट प्रोफाइल कौन सी है
यहां पर सर्च में जाऊंगा सर्च में मैंने
क्या किया
क्योंकि मैंने ऑलरेडी ओपन करके रखा होगा
क्योंकि यहां पर कुछ नहीं पर्सनल प्रोफाइल
से जो आपको ओपन हो जाएंगे आई डोंट वांट तू
पब्लिक के लिए
खुश होगी तो कुछ नहीं
हुआ
इंस्टाग्राम प्रोफाइल
थी फॉलोइंग है 12.3 मिलियन फॉलोअर्स हैं
288 पोस्ट है और ये इनकी ब्लू टिक मिला है
मतलब आपको पता ही है बाकी ये आपको पोस्ट
देखने को मिल रहे हैं ये इनकी रिलीज देखने
को मिलेगी यहां क्लिक करोगे यहां पर ये
पोस्ट देखने को मिलेंगे तो ये सब कुछ आपको
पता है और हर एक पोस्ट के ऊपर कुछ लाइक
कमेंट पर एग्जांपल मैंने क्या इसको ओपन
किया और आप क्लिक किया अभी आपको देखने को
आपको मिल रहा है देखो यहां पर ये है क्या
है कमेंट या लाइक देखने को मिल रहे होंगे
जैसे एयरपोर्ट
मिलेगा और कुछ
देखने को मिल रही है तो अब मैं इसको ऐसे
कर रहा हूं तो मतलब ये साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन
आपको पता ही है कैसे गदर करनी है कमेंट
कैसे डाउनलोड करनी है आपको कैसी चीज पोस्ट
तक पहुंचाना है तो ये बेसिक स्टेप नहीं है
बिल्कुल ये मैं अभी बच्चों की तरह बताने
वाला नहीं है जैसे की आपको ये क्या है
यहां पर लाइक देखने को मिल रही है और जैसे
की ये टैग है
[संगीत]
मैंने क्या किया की मैं इस प्रोफाइल के
लाइक्स को देखना चाहता हूं कितने लोग हैं
इसको लाइक किया हुआ है कितने लोगों ने
इसको लाइक किया हुआ अभी देखो मैं इसको
देखना चाहता हूं अभी मैं स्कोल्ड ऑन कर
रहा हूं स्कोल्ड ऑन कर रहा हूं स्कोल्ड ऑन
कर स्क्रॉल डॉ करो तो अभी देखो स्कोल्ड ऑन
करो तो काफी टाइम का है पागल मैं यहां पर
कंट्रोल एक्स करता हूं अगर मैं यहां पर
करता हूं कंट्रोल है तो मैं सर्च नहीं कर
पाऊंगा कहां पे सर्च करूंगा मैं कोई
एग्जांपल अगर मैं यहां पे सर्च करता हूं
की ए ल ए देखो यहां पर सर्च कर का रहा हूं
बट क्या है की यहां थोड़ा इजी पार्ट नहीं
अगर आप मोबाइल में उसे करते हो तो आपको
काफी इजी और सर्च ऑप्शन इधर ही देखने को
मिल जाता है नो इशू तो आपको मैं आपको कुछ
चीज बताने वाला हूं अभी स्टार्ट करने वाले
हैं देखो मैं अभी ट्रांजैक्शन मेथड के
बड़े में बात करनी है नहीं वाला क्योंकि
आप लोगों को आप लोगों को पता कर ट्रेक्शन
मेथड को कैसे उसे करना है
कुछ नहीं है जस्ट जर्नल इनफॉरमेशन गायत्री
जस्ट जनरल इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग कैसे की जैसे
आप डेली बेसिस पे आप अपने सोशल मीडिया
प्लेटफॉर्म को उसे करते हो जैसे उसमें
स्क्रॉल डॉ करते हो जैसे किसी को करते हो
जैसे की लाइक करने के बाद आप कमेंट करते
हो एवं अगर किसी की कमेंट के ऊपर कमेंट
करते हो तो आप क्या करते हो कमेंट पढ़ने
हो तो जस्ट वो क्या है की जनरल मेथड है
जिसको हम
नॉन टेक्निकल मेथड बोलते हैं लेकिन अभी
क्या है एक चीज होती है की जब भी हम क्या
करते हैं की जो लिस्ट मैंने क्या किया
लाइफ की लिस्ट अच्छी थी यहां पर जैसे पर
एग्जांपल मैंने इसको क्लिक किया यहां पर
मैं क्लिक कर रहा था लाइक के ऊपर फिर आपको
लिस्ट देखने को मिलते हैं अगले स्कोल्ड ऑन
करो स्क्रॉल डॉ कर रहा हूं तो कई जगह क्या
है की कई बार आपकी सिस्टम में इसको
रिस्टिक हुआ मिला है मतलब की अब ज्यादा
यूजर्स नहीं देख पाओगे जैसे आप मोबाइल में
स्कोडा कर रहे हो जितने अच्छे मोबाइल में
फीचर्स मिलते हैं आपको मोबाइल अप के थ्रू
वो इतने ज्यादा यहां पर देखने को नहीं
मिलेंगे तो यहां पर क्या है आपको पता है
की जो लिस्ट है इस लिस्ट में देखने के दो
ही तरीके हैं दो तरीके से इंग्लिश को आप
क्या कर सकते हो देख सकते हो जो लाइक्स के
लिए एक तो क्या है मोबाइल अप के थ्रू
लेकिन मोबाइल अप के थ्रू आप देखोगे तो
मोबाइल
हो सकते हैं
यहां पर क्या है इंस्टाग्राम में
डिस्ट्रक्शन अप्लाई किया हुआ है क्या
इंस्ट्रक्शन अप्लाई किया हुआ है
नोट टाइप का साथ के साथ बना देता हूं ताकि
आपको आइडिया हो जाएगा
1 मिनट थोड़ा सा यस यस यस
ओके नो तरीके
अगर मोबाइल एप्स
मेथड में टी एम आई टी हा ओ डी मेथड
बहुत ही लिमिटेड लिस्ट आपको देखने को
मिलती है और आपको सर्च करने की कोशिश
करूंगा आप सर्च भी नहीं कर पाओगे वो इशू
देखने में मिलता है क्योंकि यहां पे
इंस्टाग्राम में क्या कर रखा है एक
रिस्ट्रिक्शन लगा रखा है यहां पर क्या
क्या हुआ है इंस्टाग्राम ने एक
रिस्ट्रिक्शन सेट किया हुआ है ताकि आप
ज्यादा इनफॉरमेशन ना कर पे या मतलब की आप
आसानी से किसी के बड़े में अगर सर्चिंग कर
रहे हो लाइक्स के अंदर वो आसानी से मोबाइल
अप की तरह सर्च ना करता है वो
रिस्ट्रिक्शन यहां इंस्टाग्राम में आपके
ऊपर अप्लाई किया तो इंस्ट्रक्शन इस
इंस्ट्रक्शन को बाईपास करने के लिए हम
क्या कहते हैं सेकंड मेथड का उसे करते हैं
सेकंड मेथड क्या होता है सेकंड मेथड
सिंपली हम क्या करते हैं गूगल क्रोम पर
जाएंगे क्योंकि सेकंड मेथड अप्लाई करने के
लिए हमें क्या कर सकते हैं की हम गूगल
क्रोम का ही उसे करना होगा और जो आपका जो
फायरफॉक्स है उसका हम उसे नहीं कर सकते
गूगल क्रोम में जाएंगे तो ये हमारा मेटा
है तो मैं अभी मेटा की वजह मैं यहां पे
क्या सर्च करता हूं मैं सर्च करता हूं जब
जब तुम आज जाकर बैग मैंने यहां पर सर्च कर
रहा हूं अभी ओपन हो जाएगा बट टैग भी जाता
हूं या उन कोई भी पोज ऑफ एग्जांपल मुझे
इसी यही इसी पोस्ट को मैंने ओपन किया है
और मैं यहां पर क्या करता हूं लाइक्स पे
जाता हूं अभी लाइक्स हो जाता हूं तो इधर
भी से ही प्रॉब्लम है आगे स्क्रॉल डॉ करते
तब तक मैं स्कोल्ड ऑन करता रहूंगा कब तक
कब तक करता रहूंगा देखो अब बस इतना अब ये
डिस्ट्रक्शन के साथ अभी आई डोंट नो की सच
में ही इतना लाइक्स है या ज्यादा है अब
यहां पे कितना लाइक्स दे रखा है देखो
कितने लाइक से बट इसमें कितनी लिस्ट हॉकी
देखो इसमें कितनी सी लिस्ट होगी ज्यादा
लिस्ट हो नहीं की क्योंकि इंस्टाग्राम
को बाईपास करने के लिए हमारे पास एक तरीका
है
क्या तरीका है मैं आपको बता रहा हूं इस
डिस्क्रिप्शन
कर लेट हूं आप लोगों की ओके तो इस इसको
बाईपास करने के लिए आपके पास क्या तरीका
है सिंपली आपको क्या करना है अभी मैं ये
आपकी पोस्ट है कोई भी पोस्ट आपको देखने को
मिल रही है एवं मैं क्या करता हूं जो कट
करता हूं और मैं कट करता हूं तो चलो ये
पोस्ट थी मेरी यही चीज पोस्ट ओके यही
पोस्ट थी जो भी है तो मुझे क्या करना है
सिंपली इंस्टाग्राम
बन गया राइट क्लिक किया
इंस्पेक्टर आपको एक ऑप्शन दिखा दो टॉगल
डिवाइस को तो आपको सिंपली आपको क्लिक करना
होगा अब ये क्या है मोबाइल की तरह ए गया
है अब ये क्या है आपको मोबाइल की तरह
स्कोल्ड ऑन करेगा अभी ये बिल्कुल अब उसे
देखो अब ये बिल्कुल ए जैसा मोबाइल में चला
है ना ऐसे बोल रहा हूं क्या करेगा
एक बार क्लिक करते हैं यहां पर ये किसके
लिए
उसके लिए नॉर्मल कर दिया ये ओके ये टोटल
फोर मोबाइल है इसमें क्या मोबाइल के लिए
ट्रैवल कर दिया अब ये इस तरीका जैसे आपको
मोबाइल में कम कर दिया है जैसे आपके
मोबाइल में कम करते हैं देखो लाइक डेट ऐसे
ही कम है जैसे की आपके मोबाइल में ऐसे ही
कम करती है
इसको अभी जो इसका लाइक्स है देख सकते हो
लाइक कहां पे देखने को मिलती है आपको
क्लिक करता हूं यहां पर आपको मोबाइल अप की
तरह ही फीचर्स देखने को मिलेगा लेकिन देखो
क्या ये ली अफेक्टिव उतना ही फैक्ट्री में
जितना मोबाइल सब अप होती है लेकिन क्या
उससे ज्यादा है वर्किंग है उससे ज्यादा यह
वर्किंग है तो मतलब यह ऐसे देखने को मिल
रहा है एक तो यह तरीका है इस
रिस्ट्रिक्शंस को बाईपास करने का क्योंकि
इंस्टाग्राम में इसको रिस्टिक किया हुआ है
आप सिंपली क्या करोगे
गूगल क्रोम पर जाओगे राइट क्लिक करोगे
इंस्पेक्टर करोगे इंस्पेक्टर आपको टॉगल
डिवाइस यहां पर क्या आता है की आप आपको जब
भी किसी भी वेबसाइट को बनाया जाता है तो
उसको इस हिसाब से हर तरीके से बनाया जाता
है आपके डेस्कटॉप के लिए भी मोबाइल के लिए
भी टैबलेट के लिए भी हर चीज के लिए तो
यहां पर क्या है आप साइज में डिफाइन कर
सकते हैं देखो अब डाउनलोड साइज भी कर सकते
हो
कौन सा सैमसंग है आपका आईपैड मिनी आईपैड
है
अब ये क्या है बिल्कुल अब वापस वेबसाइट की
तरह दिखाई देगा तो एक ही तरीका है
बस मैं आपको दिखाना चाहता था की आप इसको
स्क्रॉल डॉ वाले रिस्ट्रिक्शन को बाईपास
करते हैं इसमें कुछ ज्यादा आपको देखने को
मिलेंगे उससे
मोबाइल अप की तरह उसे भी कर पाओगे तो एक
तो चीज ये थी आपको मैं कम करता हूं ओके
चलो चलो चलो
मार्जिन नोट इंगेज चाहिए मुझे इंगेज नहीं
चाहिए मुझे
तरीका हो गया आपको देखने को मिल रहा है
दूसरा बात करते हैं आप सबको पता है की
लास्ट क्लास में हमने पढ़ा था की स्टार जो
एएसआईसीएस है जो स्ट्रीक्स हमने पढ़ा था
इसमें भी हम उसे कर सकते हैं तो एक और
तरीका हमने पढ़ा था दो तरीका एल प्रीवियस
क्लास में हमने क्या पढ़ा था पर ए
प्रीवियस प्रीवियस क्लासेस में हमने जितना
भी पढ़ा है की किसको उसे करना स्टार्ट को
उसे करना है इसको स्टार कैसे उसे कर सकते
हो आप ऐसे उसे कर सकते हो इसको मैं बताता
हूं आपको हमे इसको ऐसे स्टार 1 मिनट स्टार
कर सकते हो अन्य नाम उसके बाद स्टार लगा
सकते हो उसके बाद क्या कर सकते हो
इस तरीके से आप कर सकते हो ये आपको क्या
है की आपके रिलेटिव फैमिली मेंबर्स फाइंड
आउट करने में हेल्प करता है और काफी
पावरफुल होता है स्टार या आपको पहले से
पता है
दिखाने की जरूर नहीं हनी चाहिए अगर मैं
इसको अगर मैं ओपन करके दिखता हूं चल इधर
दिखा भी देता हूं आपको वगैरा की मैं स्टार
करता हूं उसके बाद क्या करता हूं जकड़बाग
जड़ यू सी के आई आर बी आई आर जी इंटर किया
मैंने अभी देखो ये साड़ी क्या है जिसके
आगे लास्ट में जोकर्मक रहेगा लेकिन संत
फ्रंट में कुछ भी ना हो तो ये सारे के
सारे इसमें कम किया तो आपको पहले से ही
पता है इस चीज का स्टार को कैसे उसे करना
है तो स्टार के बड़े में आपको पता है
इसलिए मुझे इस पे ज्यादा डिस्कस करने की
जरूर नहीं है नेक्स्ट आपको पता है
प्रीवियस क्लास में हमने क्या पढ़ा था
प्रीवियस क्लास में हमने पढ़ा था एक था
हैशटैग क्या पता था
कोई भी अब इसको हम क्या बोलते हैं अब
हैशटैग क्या होता है मुझे इसके बड़े में
बताना है
की मुझे उसके बड़े में बताने की बताने की
जरूर नहीं है क्योंकि आजकल हर चीज को
फाइंड आउट करने के हर चीज छोटी-छोटी चीज
के लिए सबसे ज्यादा उसे होता है #
तो अभी आपका सबसे में कम क्या है की आपको
अपने टारगेट के बड़े में ज्यादा से ज्यादा
इनफॉरमेशन ज्यादा नहीं करनी है और ज्यादा
से ज्यादा इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग करनी है तो
उसके लिए आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा उसका
इंटरेस्ट देखना पड़ेगा क्योंकि देखो क्या
होता है की ऐसा को ऐसा कोई भी कोई भी
इंसान नहीं है दुनिया में जिसका किसी भी
चीज में कोई इंटरेस्ट है ये आपके ऊपर
डिपेंड करता है की उसका इंटरेस्ट कैसे
फाइंड आउट कर पाते हो और यही की यही एक
इंसान की सबसे बड़ी लैबोरेट्री होती है
यही सबसे बड़ी कमी होती है जो हमें पता
करनी होती है किसी भी इंसान के बड़े में
उसकी फीलींगस उसके इंटरेस्ट अगर आप वो
इंटरेस्ट फाइंड अप कर पाते हो तो इसका
मतलब क्या है की वो इंटरेस्ट कहां मिलेगा
आपको घर की घर में ही मिल जाएगा अगर आप
पैसे को कंट्रोल मॉनिटरिंग कर रही है
एडरवाइज आप सोशल मीडिया पर उसको मॉनिटर
करें तो तब भी उसका एड्रेस आपको देखने को
मिल जाएगा अगर आपको सोशल मीडिया
प्लेटफॉर्म उसका आप मॉनिटर कर रहे हो हर
चीज की आप मीना से उसको आप ट्रैक में डाला
हो आपने मीना से आप उसकी चीज के फॉलो कर
देख रहे हो तो आपको डेफिनेटली आप उसका
एड्रेस पता कर पाओगे जब आप उसका इंटरेस्ट
बताओगे तो उसके मैसेज पर आपका है आपके पास
कीबोर्ड होगा जब आपके पास कीबोर्ड होगा तो
तो आपको पता है की उसके शब्द के बेसिस पर
ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस कैसे करने क्योंकि
आपके पास टूल्स और टेक्निक्स हैं सोशल
मीडिया की उसका उसे करके आप काफी गुड
अमाउंट में और पर्टिकुलर चीज से रिलेटेड
ही आप इनफॉरमेशन कैसे कर सकते हो इसलिए
कैसे उसे करते हैं ये रहा हैशटैग ऑप्शन
सिंपली हम कर देंगे हैशटैग ए हैशटैग में
उसे करता हूं
ऐसे फुटबॉल किया मैंने फुटबॉल तो हैशटैग
हम ऐसे ही उसे कर सकते हैं इसमें सारे
के साथ साड़ी पोस्ट देखने को मिलेंगे आपको
अच्छी तरह पता है तो आई होप की मुझे
# * बेहतर के बड़े में ज्यादा डिस्कस नहीं
करना चाहिए क्योंकि इसमें जितना ज्यादा
डिस्कशन करूंगा उतना ही ज्यादा हमारा टाइम
जमीन होगा ओके उतना ही ज्यादा टाइम
कंजूमिंग होगा अब बात करते हैं हम
कंटिन्यू करते हैं अभी क्या की देखो मैंने
क्या इंडिविजुअल प्रोफाइल को टारगेट किया
होगा ये विंडो प्रोफाइल ये रही मेरी
मार्क्स अग्रवाल की मैंने इंडी प्रोफाइल
को टारगेट किया हुआ है तो अभी क्या होता
है की हमारे लिए किसी भी टारगेट के लिए
टारगेट में जितने भी पिक्चर्स होती हैं
जितनी भी वीडियो होती हैं क्योंकि ये
इंस्टाग्राम है इंस्टाग्राम में हमें
लाइक्स और लाइक के बेसिस पे भी इनफॉरमेशन
नहीं कर सकते ना ही फॉलो होगा फॉलोइंग के
बेसिस पे इनफॉरमेशन कहते इतनी ज्यादा नहीं
कर पाएंगे ना क्योंकि फॉलो फॉलोअर्स के
बेस में आप कितना पता कर पाओगे हर एक
फॉलोअर के पास जाओगे आपका टाइम कंजूमिंग
है बट क्या है की आप वीडियो और पोस्ट के
मैसेज आपको क्या ऑलरेडी इमेज ओपन 10000
करना आता है आपको इमेज एनालिसिस करना आता
है तो काफी अच्छे से आप इनफॉरमेशन कर
पाओगे तो इसलिए अभी क्या है की एक चीज
ध्यान रखना की आप किसी भी प्रोफाइल की अगर
वो पब्लिकली अवेलेबल है उसकी इनफॉरमेशन
कहते हैं ज्यादा से ज्यादा आप कर पाओगे
बहुत ही आसानी से कर पाओगे अगर वो
प्रोफाइल प्राइवेट है तो प्राइवेट
प्रोफाइल की आप इनफॉरमेशन नहीं का देंगे
कर सकते लेकिन उसके लिए आपको फरदर
एक्सप्लोरेशन करना होगा फर्डर टेक्निक उसे
करनी होगी और टैक्स उसे करनी होगी और
तरीके अलग होंगे अभी क्या है की पर एग्जाम
हमें इंस्टाग्राम की बात कर रहे हैं तो
इंस्टाग्राम में सबसे ज्यादा इनफॉरमेशन
कहते हैं की इसके थ्रू हो गया तो व्हील्स
के थ्रू होगी वीडियो जो होती है डील्स में
या किस के थ्रू होगी आपकी पोस्ट के थ्रू
होगी पोस्ट में क्या होंगे फोटोग्राफ्स
होंगे तो बेसिकली क्या है की अभी आपको पता
है की आप इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग कर रहे हो चलो
मैं मां सकता हूं की मार्क्स अग्रवाल एक
सी ओ है फाउंडर्स हैं ओके इन्होंने अपनी
पब्लिक
से प्राइवेट राखी होगी चलो उन्होंने अपनी
प्राइवेट राखी है बट क्या की कहानी ना
कहानी आपको लास्ट इनफॉरमेशन दे दे मैं
इनके फ्रेंड्स का आपको इनफॉरमेशन है और
उनकी प्रोफाइल क्या है पब्लिक है अब सीधी
सी बात है की जब आप कोई भी इनफॉरमेशन
गैदरिंग कर रहे हो इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग करते
वक्त आपको पता है की अभी आज आपको किसी कोई
भी प्रोफाइल पब्लिकली मिल रही है तो आप
उसको क्या उसके बड़े में इनफॉरमेशन छोड़िए
मत बेसिकली मेरा खाने का मतलब ये है की
जितने भी फोटोस हैं जितने भी वीडियो आपको
देखने को मिलते हैं पब्लिकली अवेलेबल
प्रोफाइल पर और आपको पता है की वो काफी
इंपोर्टेंट है
आपको इतना तो समझ में ए जाएगा आम सेंस की
हेल्प की हमारे लिए कम का होगा नहीं होगा
जो भी आपको लगता है कम का है वीडियो है
रूल्स है डॉक्यूमेंट है या फोटोस है वो
सबको क्या करना है सिंपली आपको डाउनलोड कर
लेना है और आपके जो नोट्स मेकिंग आपने जो
हैबिट बनाई है उसमें क्या करना है एड कर
लेना है क्योंकि देखो आज वो पब्लिकली है
तो कल वो प्राइवेट डेफिनेटली जाएगा अभी
क्या है की अगर वो प्राइवेट चला गया तो
उसके बाद तो क्या है की आप उसको एक्सेस ही
नहीं कर पाओगे फोटोस को उन वीडियो को
क्योंकि जैसे उसे किसी को पता चलेगा की
हां मेरे चलो किसी के बड़े में इनफॉरमेशन
कहते हैं एवं मेरे ही बड़े में इनफॉरमेशन
गधे की जा रही है उसे पता चल जाएगा ये
इनफॉरमेशन मैंने कहा डाली थी कहां मुझे
गलती हुई है जैसे उसने पता चलेगा अपने
प्रोफाइल को प्राइवेट कर दी जाए अब ये
होने से पहले क्योंकि वे आर डी हैकर्स वे
आर डी एथिकल हैकर्स तो हम उनसे ज्यादा
स्मार्ट होना चाहिए हमसे ज्यादा स्मार्ट
मतलब जब हमें मौका मिलता है किसी भी
टारगेट के बड़े में ज्यादा से ज्यादा
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग करने का और खासकर जब
पब्लिक के लिए अवेलेबल प्रोफाइल्स और आपको
पता है की आज यह पब्लिक के लिए अवेलेबल
प्रोफाइल है लेकिन इसके पास अच्छे खेस
इनफॉरमेशन है आपके टारगेट के लिए या जो
आपके कम आज के तो आपको क्या करना है उसको
सिंपली वही से स्टार्ट कर देना है डाउनलोड
करना और उसकी पुरी एक है जन्म कुंडली बना
के अपने पास या आप उसमें गूगल पे रखो वन
ड्राइव में रखो या कहानी पर भी आप उसको
डाउनलोड करके रख लीजिए क्योंकि जितनी
ज्यादा आपके पास इनफॉरमेशन होगी उतने ही
ज्यादा आप चांसेस है किसी को आप उसकी
फाइंड आउट करने में उतने ही ज्यादा चांसेस
है उसको हैकिंग सीनरी उसके अंदर आप रेड
करने के लिए इतनी ज्यादा चांसेस हैं
एक्सप्लोइटेशन करने के लिए अगर आपके पास
इनफॉरमेशन कम है उतने ही कम चांसेस है
किसी भी टारगेट को एक्सप्लॉयड ने के मोर
इनफॉरमेशन मोर चांसेस तू ट्री तू
एक्सप्लोर डी टारगेट सिंपली बात है ये तो
अभी क्या है की आपको पता चला की आपके लिए
इंपॉर्टेंट है अभी चलो आपको पब्लिक
प्रोवाइड प्रोफाइल मिलता कुछ नहीं कर सकते
लेकिन क्या है की जो भी पब्लिकली प्रोफाइल
मिल रही है लेकिन वो है हो सकता है की वो
किस टाइम बाद तो प्राइवेट जाएगी जाएगी
क्योंकि उसे पता है की इनफॉरमेशन लिखे जो
भी है उसकी वजह से भी दो की आप प्रोडक्ट
तो आपको मैं आपको बताता हूं की इनफॉरमेशन
क्या है आपको देख क्या है की आपको इतना
पता है की इमेज से किसी के बड़े में एवं
जिओ लॉकेट कैसे करना है ये आप बदले भांति
जानते हैं आप लोगों को मुझे बताने की
बिल्कुल भी जरूर नहीं है की किसी के बड़े
में आप जिओ लॉकेट कैसे कर सकते हैं अभी
मैं क्या है कुछ टूल्स टेक्निक्स बताऊंगा
की जो भी प्रोफाइल्स हैं जो भी वीडियो है
रियल से उनको डाउनलोड कैसे कर सकते हो और
एग्जांपल ये इनकी प्रोफाइल पिक्चर है अब
इसमें क्लिक करता हूं अभी क्या ये
प्रोफाइल पिक्चर कम कर रही है क्या
कर नहीं का रहा लेकिन नहीं करवाओ के मैं
कम करता हूं अगर हम इसको क्लिक कर पाओगे
इधर देखो
ओपनिंग ओपनिंग ओके अभी कैन की प्रोफाइल
पिक्चर
को वह भी नहीं कर का रहा हूं इनके बड़े
में मतलब क्योंकि आपको पता है
आपके पास होगी किसी भी टारगेट के बड़े में
है उसके बड़े में पिक्चर्स फोटोस है तो आप
ज्यादा से ज्यादा और भी अच्छी है तरीके से
लॉकेट भी कर सकते हैं और उसकी बेसिक
इनफॉरमेशन कर सकते हो चलो मैं कम करता हूं
कोई भी यह पिक्चर ओके चलो यह भी पिक्चर
हमारे पास ओरिजिनल पिक्चर देखने को तो यह
पिक्चर
[संगीत]
होगी मुझे लगता नहीं चलो एक कम करता हूं
इंस्पेक्टर
है
ये रहा
अभी क्या है एक यह पिक्चर और कहां पर
देखने को मिल रही है
क्या प्रॉब्लम
है उसके बाद क्या करना है
[संगीत]
मुझे अगर मैं इस पर क्लिक करता भी हूं
यहां पर कुछ देखने को मिल नहीं रहा वैसे
भूल गया
हूं कहां पर थी कोई भी पिक्चर
ओके पूरा पेज ए रहा है बट पिक्चर के लिए
कुछ शायद ए नहीं रहा अगर मैं यहां पर राइट
क्लिक करता हूं इस पर करता हूं चलो इधर भी
जाता हूं तो इधर भी मुझे वही चीज देखने को
मिलेगी
ओके चलो पिक्चर ये कहां है भैया
वे कैन राइट ओनली किसी सिंगल पिक्चर को या
नहीं
तुम आपको टूल्स दिखा देता हूं
क्योंकि क्या होगा जब भी आप इसको उसे
करोगे ना इसको उसे करोगे तो यहां पर क्या
की इसकी ओरिजिनल क्वालिटी की पिक्चर
डाउनलोड नहीं होगी एक्चुअल में क्या है जो
ओरिजिनल क्वालिटी है वो पिक्चर डाउनलोड
नहीं होगी तो उसके लिए हमारे पास क्या है
कुछ टूल्स हैं टूल्स भी है और
इस पिक्चर को तो सबसे पहले कौन सा टूल्स
आता है मैं आपको बात करता हूं मैं इसको
पहले एक ट्रैवल कर लेते हैं
स्क्रीनशॉट ले सकते हैं
आपको डायरेक्ट हम तुम्हें
आपको दिखता हूं
टूल्स की लिस्ट है यह रहा
सबसे पहले टूल है जो हम उसे करने वाले हैं
एक तो है
[संगीत]
देखो क्या होता है वही चीज मैं आपको बता
रहा हूं देखो स्क्रीनशॉट लोग तो कोई
बेनिफिशियल नहीं उसको मारा मेटा डाटा चेंज
हो जाएगा दूसरा अगर क्या करोगे अगर आप
विदाउट स्क्रीनशॉट हमेशा एक चीज को एक चीज
की ट्राई करना अगर तुझे जितना भी पॉसिबल
हो हमेशा एक चीज की ट्राई क्या करना है की
ओरिजिनल इमेज ओरिजिनल जो वर्जन होता है
इमेज का वो डाउनलोड करने की कोशिश करना
ओरिजिनल वर्जन डाउनलोड करने क्यों कोशिश
करना देखो एक चीज बताता हूं की जब कोई भी
इंस्टाग्राम है या फेसबुक है वो
डायरेक्टली जब न्यूज़ पे कोई भी इमेज
अपलोड होती है ना वो उसको वर्जन चेंज कर
देते हैं वो उसका वर्जन चेंज कर देते हैं
लेकिन वो क्या है नेआर्बी वर्जंस होता है
स्क्रीनशॉट लोग तो स्क्रीनशॉट में उसका
कुछ भी पता नहीं चलेगा लेकिन जब आप इस
तरीके से आप क्या है की ट्राई करोगे
डाउनलोड करने की कोई भी इमेज या फोटो तो
क्या है की जितने सोशल मीडिया प्लेटफॉर्म
उसका जो वर्जन है वो चेंज कर देते हैं
लेकिन इतना चेंज होता है
ज्यादा चेंज नहीं होता इसलिए क्या है
स्क्रीनशॉट
मुझे क्या करना है मुझे इसी को डाउनलोड
करना है कहां है
क्या करता हूं कंट्रोल
करना है
इंस्टा प्रोफाइल
साइज लेकिन छोटा साइज लेकिन लेकिन आपके
पास जो इमेज है वह
क्वालिटी में उसे बैटरी क्वालिटी में है
यह इमेज आपको देखने को मिलेगी
स्टडी प्रोफाइल को ऊपर से एक और चीज है
इसमें देखो इंस्टा स्टोरी डाउनलोड इंस्टा
वीडियो डाउनलोड और इंस्टॉल फोटो डाउनलोड
अभी यहां पर क्या है की
इसमें कुछ ऑप्शंस कम नहीं करते इसमें कुछ
ऑप्शंस कम नहीं करते इसमें कौन-कौन से
ऑप्शंस में कम करता है
इसमें एक ही कम करता है बेसिकली आपको इसे
यह वाला ऑप्शन
स्टोरी वाला भी कम करता है इसमें एवं अगर
मैं क्या करते हैं इसमें ओपन करता हूं मैं
इसको आपके सामने तो
इसमें ओनली क्या है की आपके लिए अगर
प्रोफाइल पिक्चर ही डाउनलोड करनी है
ओके तो देखिए अभी आपको देखने मिल रही है
तो इंस्टाग्राम या किसी की भी प्रोफाइल
पिक्चर डाउनलोड कर सकते हो ओनली प्रोफाइल
पिक्चर के लिए अपनी स्टोन को उसे हो नॉइस
नेक्स्ट टूल आता है नेक्स्ट टूल है जो
आपको क्या कर सकते हो आप जितनी भी आदर्श
जो पिक्चर्स है या टूल्स हैं और वो है
जितने भी पिक्चर्स और वीडियो अगर आपको
डाउनलोड करना है तो वो कर सकते हैं
पिक्चर्स वीडियो डाउनलोड करने के लिए अब
आप कौन सा तू उसे करने वाले हो ये हो गया
मेरा कम नेक्स्ट ये टूल है मेरा से था
नेक्स्ट था हमारा ये नहीं था ये नहीं था
और ये नहीं था ये क्या था
ओके यह नहीं है यह अलग है
ओके ओके ओके
डाउनलोड
करूंगा डायरेक्ट
कर पे एडरवाइज आप डाउनलोड करने में आपका
जो प्रोसेस था अपना राइट क्लिक करो वो करो
वो कर पाते ऐसे हो पे जैसे आई जेपीजी फाइल
में डाउनलोड हो गया दूसरा एक तरीका है अगर
आपने क्या करना है वीडियो डाउनलोड करनी है
तो वीडियो भी डाउनलोड कर सकते हो कैसे कर
सकते हो
बैक करता हूं तो ये तरीका है
पोस्ट में थे क्वेश्चन दे देना
साड़ी चीजों को संस्कृत कर रहे हैं ना
बताइए
इसको डाउनलोड कर देगा डायरेक्ट यहां पर
डाउनलोड
करता है
इंस्ट्रक्शन सुना हम क्या कर देंगे एड कर
देंगे
चलो चलो हो गया ना
ओके अब मैं क्या करता हूं ये मेरा
प्रोफाइल है ये कहानी भी है देखो अभी मैं
इसको बैक करता हूं अभी मैं यहां पर क्या
करता हूं
इसको रिफ्रेश कर देता हूं एक बार
क्लिक करता हूं
यार
आपको ऐसे देखने को मिलेगा
मैं क्या करता हूं इस पर चला हूं बैक करता
हूं एक बार और इसको क्लोज करता हूं क्रोम
एक्सटेंशन को इसको क्योंकि हमने एक्शन से
एड कर लिया
ऑप्शन क्या है
ओके ओके
बड़ी मुश्किल से एक्सटेंशन आप लोग मिलते
हैं और वही कम नहीं करते
डाउनलोड
आई डोंट नो
कंपनी
डाउनलोड ऑप्शन
बताना है
बट अगर मैं इसको डाउनलोड जो ऑप्शन करता
हूं एक मिनट देखना
यहां पर डाउनलोड जो ऑप्शन
डाउनलोड जो ऑप्शन में आपके साथ है की आप
ब्लॉक हो सकते हो
अब लॉक हो सकते हो चेस है यहां पर क्योंकि
instagram.com
इस तरीके से आपको देखने को मिलेगा
की इंस्टाग्राम आपको ब्लॉक कर सकता है
देखने को मिल रहा है जैसे आपको स्क्रीन पर
दिखाई दे रहा है इसका मतलब क्या है की ये
ऐसे कम कर रहा है बट मेरे पास पता नहीं
क्यों नहीं कम कर रहा मैंने अभी विदाउट
मशीन किया था तो फिर वर्किंग बट नो इट्स
नोट वर्किंग
वन क्लिप में डाउनलोड करना
है
तो एक कम कर देना ग्रुप में स्क्रीनशॉट
भेज देना की ये इधर भी शो कर रहा है वैसे
डाउनलोड ऑप्शन भी अगर मैं इसको डाउनलोड
करता हूं यस यस यस यस
ये हो गया यस यस वर्किंग इट्स वर्किंग
इट्स वर्किंग यस यह रहा यह रहा यह रहा इधर
इधर अगर हम क्या करते हैं बैक करते हैं
चलो हमारे रेल है पर एग्जांपल
नो नो एंड्राइड
यूज्ड इन एंड्राइड
ऑन स्क्रीन ओके इट्स वर्किंग तो और आपको
देखिए अगर और यहां पर डाउनलोड जो करोगे
ट्राई तू अवॉइड डाउनलोड जो बिकॉज़ यहां से
आप ब्लॉक हो सकते हो अगर हर एक पोस्ट पर
एक बिल पे जो आपको इंटरेस्टिंग लगता हैं
उसपे जाइए जैसे इस पे क्लिक करोगे तो यहां
पर जैसे ये आपको देखने को मिल जाता है
यहां पर डाउनलोड कर पाओगे ये काफी अच्छा
एक्सटेंशन है आप किसी अप पे जो इसी वाले
को कॉपी करोगे उसके बाद पेस्ट करो पेस्ट
करने के बाद डाउनलोड करोगे तो मैंने क्या
है तीन टूल्स को आपके बड़े में बता इन इन
तीन सोल के बड़े में आपको बताया एक और तो
एक और एक्सटेंशन होता है आपके सामने लेकर
आता हूं तो एक एक्सटेंशन
अब यह क्या है सिंगल फाइल करके यह
एक्सटेंशन है सिंगल फाइल करके तो मैं करता
हूं सिंगल फाइल तो यहां पर क्या कर सकते
हो आप अकॉर्डिंग तू योर फायरफॉक्स का शॉप
यहां पर क्लिक कीजिए फाइव फॉक्स पे 10
फायरफॉक्स का एक्सटेंशन में चला जाएगा
डाउनलोड फायर डायरेक्शन सर मैंने क्या कर
दिया इसको फायरफो गेट कर दिया ये क्या
करता है की जो आपकी टारगेट प्रोफाइल है ना
जो अभी ट्राई किया उसको पुरी की पुरी एक
फाइल में डाउनलोड कर देता है पुरी की पुरी
एक फाइल में डाउनलोड कर देता है पुरी पुरी
फाइल में क्या करता है डाउनलोड कर देता है
तो उससे आपको बेनिफिट क्या है
की आप ऑफलाइन हो जाए आप जैसे-जैसे स्क्रॉल
डॉ करते हैं हम आपको दिखता हूं एग्जांपल
[संगीत]
है
यहां पर कौन-कौन सा है
हमारे पास ओके आई बिल डाउनलोड
व्हाट आई एम डूइंग ब्रो
चलो हम इधर करते हैं
है
डाउनलोड
कर देगा डाउनलोड कर देगा
ओके ओके एक बार एक बार डाउनलोड होने दो यह
आपको शो कर देगा
पुरी इसके क्या आपके लोकल फाइल के अंदर
डाउनलोड कर देगा जो आपके लोकल एन उसके
अंदर पूरा डाउनलोड कर देगा ये और स्क्रीन
है अब ये क्या अपलोड हो रहा है क्योंकि
इसमें क्या कहते हो तो आपका स्टोरेज है
उसके ऊपर क्या कर दिया इसने डाउनलोड कर
दिया अब इन नो नो नो मैंने क्लिक कर दिया
था डोंट वांट तू क्लिक ऑन बस में ओन्ली
इनफॉरमेशन कहते हैं देखो बस ये अभी क्या
है इतना ही है ये रहा आपको देखने को मिल
रहा है
पूरा पूरा एड्रेस
कर दिया गया तो देखिए
आगे एक और इसमें इंटरेस्टिंग ऑप्शन आपको
करके दिखता हूं ये तो क्या है की
जैसे-जैसे किसी भी प्रोफाइल में जैसे
मैंने यहां पर क्लिक किया जैसे आपको किसमे
इंटरेस्ट है आपको किसी तागड़ी इमेज में
इंटरेस्ट है कैसे ये आपको लगता है इस
पोस्ट में इंटरेस्ट है क्योंकि ये जो साथ
में दिखाई दे रहा है इसमें इंटरेस्ट आपको
सीधे आपने जैसे इस पर क्लिक किया तो यहां
पर क्या है की इसको भी वैसे मैं क्लिक
करता हूं तो इसी को क्या कर दिया इसी की
बेसिक पे फॉर्मेशन आपके लिए एक पेज में
डाउनलोड कर देगा अभी देखते हैं ये डाउनलोड
कर रहा है कर रहा है कर रहा है कर रहा है
ऐसी कोई ओके इसको भी इसने कर दिया अब इसको
मैं ओपन करता हूं
पुरी इनफॉरमेशन उसने क्या कहती है डाउनलोड
कर दिया अगर मुझे इतना स्कोर डॉ करता है
उतना डाउनलोड करना अब एक चीज कर सकते हैं
इसके साथ एक चीज कर सकते हैं बार-बार हमें
क्या करना पद रहा है डाउनलोड करना पड़ा
इसके साथ हम एक काफी इंटरेस्टिंग चीज क्या
कर सकते हैं ये है की मैं क्या कहता है
राइट क्लिक ऑन डी आईकॉन मैंने क्या कहा
गया है जो आईकॉन था मेरा ये रहा ये आईकॉन
आपको कोनी में दिखाई दे रहा हूं मैं राइट
क्लिक किया राइट क्लिक करने के बाद मुझे
इस पे जाना है सिंगल फाइल सिंगल फाइल पे
क्लिक करूंगा तो ऑटो से जाना मेरे जैसे
ऑटो एक मिनट सिंगल फ्लेयर एक मिनट या
ओके ओके जैसे ये रहा
रेड क्लिक कर रहा हूं मैं
सिंगल फाइल पर क्लिक कर रहा हूं
उसके बाद इसको क्लिक करने वाले ऑप्शन
मैंने यहां पर क्लिक कर दिया ऑटो से ओल्ड
टैब अभी क्या है की जैसे मैंने क्या किया
चलो एक मिनट इसको कट कर रहा हूं अरे यार
चलो मैं इसको अभी बैंड कर देता हूं इसको
क्लोज कर देता हूं चलो यह मेरी प्रोफाइल
फाइल आप देखना
है मुझे किस पोस्ट में क्या है इंटरेस्ट
है एवं मैंने इसको क्या किया ओपन न्यू तब
उसके बाद ओपन न्यू तब किया ये इसको भी
डाउनलोड कर दिया सबको डाउनलोड कर देगा
मुझे इसमें इंटरेस्ट है यहां पर मैंने
इसको डॉ किया स्क्रॉल डॉ स्क्रॉल डॉ मुझे
ये लगता है की ये रहा ये कोई पोस्ट है ये
रही इसमें कोई इंटरेस्ट लगता है ओपन न्यू
तब जैसे मैं जितने टाइप ओपन करो ये रहा
इसको भी ये क्या कर देगा डाउनलोड कर देगा
इसकी जीवन जो जो भी है चाट है जो स्कोल्ड
ऑन कर रहा स्क्रॉल डॉ कर रहा हूं क्योंकि
फर्डर नस करना है अगर आपको बाद में
एनालिसिस करना है तो आप
क्रोम डाउनलोड कैसे करें
बताइए
यह मैसेज
डाउनलोड
जो टैब कर रहे हैं ऑटो से करेगा बट
एटलिस्ट अभी देखा अभी सभी को कर रहा था
सभी को धीरे-धीरे धीरे-धीरे सबको करवा दे
इतने सारे डाउनलोड कर दिया मैंने क्या अब
इसको मैंने ओपन किया ये भी इसमें क्या है
डाउनलोड कर देगा इसको भी डाउनलोड
मिलेगा इसको किसी को भी ओपन कर रहा हूं
मैं इसको ओपन किया देखो ये इसमें ऑलरेडी
इसमें डाउनलोड किया हुआ मिला अगर इसको मैं
इस पे जाता हूं इसको मैं इसने क्या कर
दिया सारे के सारे डाउनलोड कर दिया तो
काफी इंटरेस्टिंग टूल है ये भी
क्रोम डाउनलोड कैसे करें किसमे क्रोम
डाउनलोड करना है बताइए तो मुझे एक चीज
बताइए अभी तक जो भी मैं बता रहा हूं आप
लोगों को जितने भी टूल्स बता रहा है आपको
समझ में ए रहे नहीं ए रही है बताइए
क्योंकि मैंने आपको तीन टूल्स दो एक्शन से
सिंगल फाइल के बड़े में बताया ये रहा आपको
देखने में मिल रहा है या सिंगल फाइल
डाउनलोड
[संगीत]
जितने भी आज से इंस्टाग्राम से रिलेटेड
उसे कर रहे हैं ना एक्सटेंशंस हैं एवं जो
भी है वो सब कुछ आपको आपके उसे ग्रुप में
मिल जाएंगे बस एटलिस्ट में मैं बता दूंगा
अभी ओके मैं बता दूंगा तो अभी आपको समझ
में ए रहा है की जितने भी टूल्स मैंने
आपको बताया की सारे समझ में ए जाए क्या है
की मैंने कितने टूल्स को उसे किया है की
सिंगल फाइल को उसे किया है आईडी डाउनलोड
कोई उसे किया है और स्टार्टिंग में ये रहा
एक आईडी डाउनलोड हो गया उससे पहले मैंने
एक इसको उसे किया था ये कहां गया है उसको
मैंने कट कर दिया
प्रोफाइल पिक्चर डाउनलोड करना चाहता हूं
अभी डाउनलोड कर सकते हो अदर वाइस क्या कर
सकते हो आप सबसे बेस्ट आपके पास एक क्रोम
एक्सटेंशन है
और उसके अलावा एक और तू बताया था मैंने जो
भी आप क्या कर सकते उसका भी उसे कर सकते
हो
उसका भी आप उसे कर सकते हो तो मुझे एक चीज
बताइए अभी तक जितने भी एक्सटेंशन मैंने आप
लोगों को बताया आप सबको समझ में ए रहे हैं
या नहीं ए रहा है बताइए
डिस्क्रिप्शन ओके
एक बार वीडियो देखना पड़ेगा व्हाट इसे डी
प्रिंस आज क्या थोड़ा समय फास्ट बोल रहा
हूं या बताइए
आपको क्या ग रहा है की फास्ट है या कुछ
क्लियर सुने नहीं दे रहा प्लीज बताइए
ओके ओके चलो फिर हमने कम करते हैं एक दो
टूल्स के बड़े में और डिस्कशन करें या और
करना बताइए
एक दो टूल्स के बड़े में डिस्कशन करें और
करें बताइए
ओके तो चलो अभी हम बात करते हैं नेक्स्ट
और एक और मेरे पास टूल है अगर मैं मैंने
यह करवा दिया आपको बता दिया चलो यह मैंने
आपको आईडी डाउनलोड हो बता दिया ये बता
दिया मैंने ये बता दिया एक टूल है आपके
पास एक मिनट ये नहीं ये रही ये नहीं ये ये
रहा एक टूल है पीकॉक की डॉट कॉम पिको
ki.com एक तुले काफी इंटरेस्टिंग टूल आपको
बताता हूं की ये ये कैसे इंटरेस्टिंग है
इसको मैं क्लोज करता हूं इसको मैं क्लोज
करता हूं इसको क्लोज करता हूं इसको क्लोज
करता हूं और ये अपना और इसको मैं क्या
करता हूं कंट्रोल भी और इंटर अभी मैंने
क्या इस टूर को मैंने क्या किया ओपन किया
है पेपर ki.com अभी यहां पर क्या कर सकते
हो कोई भी यूजर नाम लिख सकते हो या टैग कर
सकते हो यहां पर क्या है की पर एग्जांपल
जितने भी अब यहां पर चांसेस क्या है यहां
चांसेस क्या है की आपका जो टारगेट है उसके
एक से ज्यादा भी अकाउंट हो सकते हैं
इंस्टाग्राम पर अगर एक से ज्यादा अकाउंट
हो सकते हैं तो वैसे तो आपको देखने को
नहीं मिल रहे बट
बेट आप इसके हिसाब इसके साथ आपको पता कर
सकते हो बाहर से कम हो सकता है इनके
रिलेटिव भी हो या होम भी उनके घरवाले भी
हो सकता है कोई इन्हीं के नाम से मार्ग
नाम से इन्होंने अपना कोई अकाउंट बनाया
हुआ है या इस यूजर नाम से किसी इनके
फैमिली मेंबर ने बनाया हुआ है तो सारे
देखो यहां पे लेट्स ऑफ इनफॉरमेशन है इस
प्रोफाइल से रिलेटेड नोट्स अभी ये सारे
क्या है सारे अकाउंट्स आपको देखने में
मिलते हैं काफी कुछ देखने को मिलता है आप
इसको टैग्स भी देखने को मिलते हैं देखो
यहां पर है
ये बहुत सारे टैग्स आज हम इसमें किसी पे
क्लिक करता हूं काफी इंटरेस्टिंग है यहां
पर काफी कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग इनफॉरमेशन आपको
देखने को मिलती है अभी देखो इसमें मैं
क्लिक करता हूं तो देखो ये साड़ी साड़ी
इसी से रिलेटेड क्या पोस्ट भी देखें हुए
मिल जाएंगे
पोस्ट देखने को मिल जाएंगे जितने फोर्स
देखने को मिल जाएगी बैक करता हूं तो अब
मैं करता हूं उसके बाद में फिर और बैक
करता हूं तो ये भी टूल काफी इंटरेस्टिंग
है देखो मैं क्या आप लोग टूल के नाम बताता
जाऊंगा अब टूल को कैसे उसे करना है आपको
पता है अगर आपको देखो टूल्स के बड़े में
मैं डीटेल्स में जाऊंगा तो फिर आपको क्या
है की आप क्या करोगे
डिटेल में जाता अभी आगे बाहर एक पेज को
डाउनलोड कर यार नो नो नो नो नो इसको मैं
क्या करता हूं
इसको क्या करता हूं अभी सिंगल फाइल फोटो
से डिसएबल
अभी क्या है अगर मैं हर एक टूल के बड़े
में आपको बताऊंगा तो अब क्या करोगे
गूगल सर्च कर लीजिए उसके बेस पे किसी ने
किसी ने आर्टिकल लिखे होंगे और वो आर्टिकल
आप क्या कर सकते हो पढ़ भी सकते हो किसी
भी टोल के बड़े में टूल कैसे कम कर सकता
है क्योंकि आर्टिकल उसमें लिखने के लिए
मेरे को टाइम नहीं मिलता क्योंकि मैं बहुत
साड़ी चीज बहुत सारे एक्सेस लेट हूं इसलिए
आर्टिकल लिखने के लिए टाइम नहीं मिलता अगर
मैं भी लिख सकता हूं बट जब ऑलरेडी अवेलेबल
है तो वहां से आप आर्टिकल देख सकते तो
उनका सिंपली नाम डालिए और आप क्या कर सकते
हैं इस तरीके से
रिफ्रेश कर लेट हूं
प्रोफाइल इसे प्राइवेट प्रोफाइल प्राइवेट
दोस्त क्या है ओपन नहीं कर सकते आप और
जैसे की यहां पर और भी कुछ है टूल का उसे
करना आपका कम है अभी टूल का उसे करना है
आपका कम है अभी मैं क्या करता हूं यहां पर
ट्रेंडिंग ट्रेंडिंग में जाता तो आपको
देखना है देखने को मिलेगा इंसुलेटेड
ट्रेंडिंग क्या है देखो ट्रेंडिंग में
क्या चल रहा है अभी ट्रेंडिंग में भी वो
सा चीज है अगर मैं ये कम मैंने हां यूजर
नाम लिखा था ना मैंने
[संगीत]
क्लिक किया तो
अब यह देखने को मिल गया तो इस टूल को एक
तरीके से आप ऐसे भी उसे कर सकते हैं अगर
एक ही अकाउंट एक यूजर नाम के मल्टीपल
अकाउंट्स का फाइंड आउट करना चाहते हो तो
एक ये टूल्स है नेक्स्ट टूल्स की बात करते
हैं हमारा जो कॉन्सेप्ट है अगर आप क्या
चाहते हो जितने भी जो लाइक्स हैं किसी भी
पोस्ट के ऊपर जितने भी लाइक्स हैं
फॉलोेइंग है या फॉलोज हैं वो लवर्स उनको
क्या करना चाहता हूं एनालिसिस करना चाहते
हो एनालिसिस कैसे करोगे आप स्क्रॉल डॉ
करके तो एनालिसिस नहीं कर सकते उसके लिए
आप अगर आप क्या करना चाहते हो एक्सल
फॉर्मेट में क्या करना चाहता हूं उसको से
करना चाहते हो कैसे करोगे वो करने के लिए
आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा एक एक्शंस फ्रॉम
एक्सटेंशन है क्रोम एक्सटेंशन नाम है ये
रहा ये रहा इसको मैं क्या करता हूं
कंट्रोल सी करता हूं और अपने क्रोम पर
चलते हैं और चलते हैं अपने क्रोम पे और
इसको मैं क्या करता हूं अभी बैंड करता हूं
इसको भी बैंड करता हूं
और ये करता हूं
कंट्रोल भी अच्छा चलो बेस्ट फ्रेंड को
यहां पर क्षेत्र में मैं क्या कर रहा हूं
एड कर देता हूं इसे एक्सटेंशन
आपको देखने को मिलेगा हम इसको क्या करता
हूं पी कर देता हूं
अब ये क्या है आपको साइन इन विद गूगल ओके
[संगीत]
पूजा
अब बोल के साथ साइन करना पड़ेगा क्योंकि
मेरे पास है
अभी मैंने क्या इसमें अभी कर नहीं सकता
चलो एक और है ये क्या है किसको क्या कर
सकता है क्या करने का कम है प्लगइन काफी
इंपॉर्टेंट प्लगइन है एवं जो फॉलोवरिंग है
फॉलोअर्स को क्या है अगर आप क्या कहना
चाहते हो एक्सल फाइल में फाइल में से केवल
करना चाहते हैं जितने भी फॉलोइंग
उसको कन्वर्ट करने के कम आता है दूसरा अगर
आप कमेंट करना चाहते हो अगर आप कमेंट को
क्या करना चाहते हो
एक्सल फाइल मत करना
कंट्रोल सी करता हूं इसको मैं और इसके
अंदर जाता हूं मैं और मैं क्या करता हूं
आपको अगर यहां पर लेकर चला हूं ये रहा
नेक्स्ट पेज पर एक और क्रोम एक्शन से नाप
एड कर लीजिए तो मैं टीम से एड करवा दूंगा
डोंट वारी यह रहा एड क्रोम कीजिए यहां पर
ये भी एक्सटेंशन कर दिया अभी आई थिंक ये
भी साइन इन के मांगेगा क्या आ ओके साइन इन
कीजिए
इसका पासवर्ड याद नहीं है मेरा
नो नो नो नो नो नो नो नो नो नो नो
बट मुझे अभी साइन करने के लिए मुझे क्या
करना पड़ेगा
एक मिनट अगर मैं इधर करके दिखता हूं अगर
मैं इधर दिखता हूं इसको क्रोम करूंगा अगर
मैं एड करूं क्या मैंने एड एक्सटेंशन इधर
मैं करता हूं एक मिनट आपके लिए सॉल्यूशन
निकलता हूं अगर ये इधर मैंने क्या किया है
स्क्वायर तो क्रोम किया
प्लीज इंस्टॉल तू इंस्टाग्राम और ट्री
अगेन
ओके अब मैं इसको यहां पर लॉगिन नहीं कर
सकता इट्स मी प्रॉब्लम यहां पर तो ये कर
गया इसमें प्रॉब्लम
इसको मैं यहां उसे कर सकता
इंस्टाग्राम
ओके
कंट्रोल
[संगीत]
के साथ ही आऊंगा
एडिक्शन मैनेजमेंट
चाहिए ओके सबको साइन इन चाहिए बट क्या है
की मैं आपको ये एड करवा दिया एक्सटेंशन
आपको और भी एक्सटेंशन हो गया
एक और
चीज है ये एक इसके बड़े में डिस्कस कर
लेते चलो कंट्रोल सी करता हूं एक और ये
वेबसाइट है कंट्रोल भी कर देता हूं
इसके बड़े में डिस्कशन कर लेते हैं
लाइक्स को कमेंट को फॉलो से फॉलोइंग को
अगर कैसे आप एक्सल फॉर्मेट में उसपे डाटा
को इंपोर्ट कर सकते हो एक्सपोर्ट कर सकते
हो वो कैसे वो सीखना हूं मैं नेट क्लास
मैं अभी मैं बात करते हैं हम अगर
की जो है आपकी क्या है
स्टैटिसटिक्स एनालिसिस स्टेटिक एनालिसिस
क्या होता है ये
ओनली इंस्टाग्राम
जब यह मटर
है
आपको देखने को मिल रही है
यहां पर क्या है देखो इसका किसकी प्रोफाइल
है ट्विटर प्रोफाइल
आप बट इसके भी मुझे क्या करना पड़ेगा
रजिस्टर करना पड़ेगा तो इसके लिए मुझे
क्या करना और इसके बाद क्या टिक टॉक की
प्रोफाइल देखो वेयर मेटा ये मटर ट्वीट की
प्रोफाइल है और भी आपको देखने को मिल रहा
है बट यहां पे मुझे इसको भी उसे करने के
लिए क्या करना पड़ेगा
रजिस्टर करना होगा लॉगिन करना होगा
प्रॉब्लम यह है मेरे पास प्रॉब्लम यह है
उसको भी मुझे रजिस्टर और लॉगिन करना होगा
तो एक कम करें हम नेक्स्ट क्लास में ही
इनको पढ़ने वाले इंस्टॉल
बेसिकली उसे किया जाएगा बाकी जो आपका
लाइक्स को कैसे एक्सपोर्ट किया जितने भी
लाइक्स हैं किसी पर्टिकुलर पोस्ट के ऊपर
आप ऐसे इंडिविजुअल स्कोर डॉ करके तो नहीं
कर सकते अगर आप क्या करते उसको एक्सल
फॉर्मेट में कन्वर्ट करना चाहते हो तो आप
भी काफी कुछ इनफॉरमेशन बोलते हैं मिल जाति
है तो उसको कैसे कन्वर्ट कर सकते हो
एक्सपोर्ट कर सकते हो कमेंट को कैसे
एक्सपोर्ट कर सकते हो एवं एडरवाइज कमेंट
के बजे अगर हम वो भी फॉलो या फॉलोइंग को
भी एक्सपोर्ट करना चाहता हूं अभी हम
एक्सपोर्ट कर सकते हैं तो आई एम सॉरी पर
डेट टुडे हम इतना ही मुझे लगता है की यहां
पर ही कर पे क्योंकि आज मुझे इसका ध्यान
नहीं दिया की मुझे लॉगिन करना क्योंकि
मैंने कुछ सच में एड नहीं किया था इससे
पहले टूल्स को तो मैं देख चुका था बट इनको
आप लोगों के सामने परफॉर्म कर रहा था बट
एक कम करते हैं
तो हम एक कम करते हैं और
क्या सबको मेरी आवाज ए रही है ना
तो कम करते हैं हम सेशन को एड करते हैं आज
के लिए और प्लीज जाकर किसी को कोई भी डाउट
है तो
पूछ लीजिए आप लोगों के लिए
2 मिनट तो वेट कर ही लेते हैं
ओके क्रोम डाउनलोड
सबको स्क्रीन भी क्लियर दिखाई दे रही है
ना
हर्ष क्या हाय लेवल का क्या बताना बताओ
आर्टिकल फोटो डाउनलोड कर पाओगे
कंट्रोल सी ओपन करता हूं तो आप लोग के लिए
चलो
यहां से पढ़ लीजिए अगर आप तब भी आप क्रोम
डाउनलोड कर का रहे तो आपको आसानी से कम कर
पाओगे
लिंक भेजो आपको मिला नहीं क्या
मैंने आपको लिंक भेजो नहीं मिला क्या
विंडो कैसे डाउनलोड करें इसमें विंडो
डाउनलोड करने के लिए आपको पहले वसल बॉक्स
डाउनलोड करना पड़ेगा से डीएम एमवेयर का
आपको क्या करना है डाउनलोड करना है ये रहा
नेक्स्ट
सिंपली करो तो डाउनलोड करोगे
क्लिक करो जैसे क्लिक करोगे यहां आपको यह
क्या डाउनलोड करना शुरू कर देगा
ओके
डाउनलोड हो जाएगा
किसी को फॉलो करके आप कर सकते हो ओके
और रिजेक्ट कर दिया होगा चलो
सिंपली स्टेप है
उसके इंस्टॉल कर दो और जैसे ही आप इंस्टॉल
करोगे
हां एमवेयर भी ऐसे उसका दीप है क्या जी आप
कर सकते हो
भैया
या नहीं मूड है आप लोगों से सिलेंडर करने
का बताओ
हेलो यार
करते हो